Excuse me, do you know where the art room is?
Sure. It is on the fifth floor.
Use the elevator and go to the fifth floor.
Is it easy for me to find it on the fifth floor?
You have to turn right out of the elevator.
Then go past the stairs.
On your left, you will see the art room.
Thanks a lot.
It is easy to find. You can't miss it.
Gordon was a new kid at school, and he stood alone in the hall.
He had to go to music class, but he didn't know where to go.
The music room wasn't on the first floor. He went up the stairs.
He knew he had to hurry cause his teacher would be worried.
At the top of the stairs, he turned right down the hall.
On the left, he saw a door. Oh, No! It was the art room.
He turned right out of that room, and went past the stairs.
On the left, he saw a door. That is the music room!